family united amidst tragedy love you
Dad Bruce Willis's three eldest
daughters with X Demi Moore rumor Scout
and Tallulah all thanked fans for the
outpouring of support we spoke with Dr
Allison Reese of the Alzheimer's
Foundation of America to get insight
into Bruce's newly revealed frontal
temporal dementia diagnosis it's a group
of diseases that have the common factor
that the brain loses brain cells the
average life expectancy from when you
get the first symptoms is about eight to
ten years and the reason is that a body
without a brain can't maintain the
unfortunate thing is there's not much
you could do about it which is
so sad and tragic the family confirms
Bruce is facing challenges with
communication due to this cruel disease
multiple sources told ET quote on his
last several films he was fitted with an
earpiece and someone had to read him as
lines because he was unable to remember
them
you can see what appears to be an
earpiece in both 2022's American Siege
and 2021's Fortress
E.T last interviewed Bruce with devoted
second wife Emma at his 2018 Comedy
Central roast are you feeling nervous
excited what not nervous
and now Bruce's speech from inside
illustrating his fighting Spirit has
gone viral and I've been attacked by
terrorists asteroids male pattern
baldness and none of it none of it
stopped me because I am still Bruce
Willis
another Hollywood icon who leaned on
humor through unimaginable struggles the
late Olivia Newton-John tell me
last word she could say to me was my
sunshine and and
right before she lost her ability to
speak she was making jokes Olivia's
daughter Chloe lotanzi emotionally spoke
out for the first time since losing her
mom to breast cancer last August she's
my mama I'm so glad that she was Olivia
Newton-John for so many people
foreign